seid ihr bereit für nutzen bzw
schmalzgebäck beziehungsweise bay netz
ausgesprochen bei küss den frosch gab
sie nämlich auch und die machen wir
heute das ist ein free tier gebäck das
so ein bisschen knusprig aber auch soft
ist wartet den test ab ihr werdet es
nicht bereuen und wir gehen direkt an
die zubereitung kommt mit
[Musik]
ich rühre zwar schnell den teig zusammen
dafür habe ich alle zutaten bereit
stehen und er ist auch super
unkompliziert weil wirklich einfach
alles zusammen gerührt wird und ich
schreibe euch natürlich alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben unten in die
infobox wichtig ist halt nur dass die
mutter schon so ein bisschen weicher
geworden ist dann verbindet sich das
alles gleich besser als zucker mit dazu
geben das wird ein alkoholfreies rezept
normalerweise ist wirklich immer rom
dabei ich benutze um aroma das gibt
nochmal echten ja besonderen geschmack
aber halt alkoholfrei
[Musik]
der teig ist fertig ich habe übrigens
mehl und backpulver kurz vor abfahrt und
dann abwechselnd mit der milch dazu
gegeben dann habt ihr einfach keine
gefahr dass es sich nicht gut verbindet
das funktioniert einfach ein bisschen
besser jetzt den ganzen tag immer
rausnehmen und die welt merken das ist
so ein tag der fühlt sich eins zu eins
so andere ohrläppchen ihr könnt gerne
mal testen und so ist er dann genau
richtig ich werde jetzt den teig einmal
nehmen kurz ein bisschen zusammen kneten
und dann kommt er in die
frischhaltefolie denn er braucht jetzt
noch mal so ein bisschen ruhe also eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank legen
und in der zwischenzeit beziehungsweise
kurz vor ende der kühlzelle ich schon
mal mein fett erhitzen
[Musik]
so mein fett ist fertig ich hab einfach
frittierfett den mann hoch anfang
gegeben wir können nämlich auch topf
nehmen und er kennt das fett das ist
ready ist wenn ihr einen schaschlikspieß
hinein haltet und die bläschen relativ
langsam aufsteiger sie dürfen mich
extrem sprudelt aufsteigen es ist zu
heiß sie sollten wirklich langsam
aufsteigen so jetzt habe ich hier meinen
teil der ist schön früh da wird aber
nicht so fest gegen habt also so dürft
ihr euch das jetzt nicht vorstellen so
entspannt einfach nur ein bisschen und
jetzt ich mache es so dass ich da so ein
bisschen mehl auf die arbeitsfläche gebe
einfach damit da nichts dran an belebt
und dann wird da 1 cm dick ausgebreitet
dafür habe ich hier meinen aus neustadt
hier sich der abstand schreiben habe ich
da die 1 cm scheiben dran und jetzt
einfach ausrollen und typisch ist ja
wirklich ihr könnt noch ein bisschen
drüber machen typisch ist er wirklich
diese rautenform und dass das in so
geschlängel linien ausgeschnitten wird
und dafür nehme ich einfach mein talk
mädchen
[Musik]
also ich finde jetzt ein zentimeter hat
doch ein bisschen dick muss ich sagen
wobei ist es komplett euch überlassen ob
der see trick oder dünn macht das ist
halt nur ein unterschied beim frittieren
und sie brauchen halt ein bisschen
länger wenn es dicker ist und ihr habt
dann halt viel lob super viel teig und
sie plustern sich noch mal richtig auf
was ja auch komisch ist aber ich habe
jetzt noch mal die 6 mm abschreiben dran
gemacht und wer ist es noch ein bisschen
dünner aus freuen und dann wie gesagt
die rauchen ausschneiden und dann kommen
wir schon direkt ins frittierfett
[Musik]
ihr dürft euch zu hause übrigens nicht
wundern dass das scheuen das ist ganz
normal weil er teilt ja kalt ist und
wenn kaltes bahrain kommen dann kann es
halt anfangen zu träumen das überhaupt
kein problem und ich habe treibt man die
zeit angehalten weil ich mach doch mal
nach gefühl aber
eineinhalb bis maximal zwei minuten
brauchen die mutzen jetzt im fett und
dann könnte sie rausnehmen und ich habe
jetzt hier so ein up kipper und darunter
ein bisschen küchenpapier und lass das
abtropfen bevor das puderzucker drauf
kommt
[Musik]
wird echt hält ist ist das ist ja schon
mal was man gesehen auch in mainz
michael jackson ist noch nicht
gesprochen das sind nutzen bzw mit dem
ganzen region auch schmalzgebäck pizzen
nützen ja wo wir gerne weil ich bin echt
gespannt wie du sie finde ist wenn das
gebiss hat das war ich für mich
geschubst
schweizerische macht
auf jeden fall probieren wir schon mal
was dass ich echt fragen muss jetzt
nicht gerade schon gelöscht es ist ein
free täter teig und
brannten ein
netter versuch aber es ist das komisch
ist es ist teilt manfred hirt den teig
und man denkt auch jeder frittierte
tagen fiel gleich aber es ist so eine
knusprige ein
so bist du wirst aber auch so puttrich
auf jeden fall für der abgang ist
einfach sooo geil dieses knackige und
weiche das ist ja das so außen knusprig
und innen so weiß man kann es gar nicht
beschreiben auf jeden fall mit
puderzucker haben mal lecker machen echt
60 könnte ganz schlimm heute kasse von
recherchen beschwert und körper dabei
wie möglich zu finden das ist mein
spruch ich sagen werde aber es ist schon
echt einfach auch so schnecken also
braucht wenig zutaten schmeckt heftig
also dass danach machen macht nachhinein
also leute macht's gut
[Musik]